three or four more points per game
doesn't sound like a lot now it would be
a big deal
Russell for three you just got a play
off of it Lutz will find you forced shot
by Russell over the top of the 7-footer
boots of it shake his hand and one do
bad stuff with Russell Weston and
Russell makes it pay
[Applause]
Narus into the paint fact of the Angelo
Russell another three boy if not for
Russell the nets would be in big trouble
Jonathan Isaac they've got the vets with
under a minute to play in the first half
fallout 3 by Russell's 21 for D'Angelo
Russell Russell
it's got 24 there's really wants to get
his on visit and go on Aragorn has been
really good Russell another three get to
the big fella small man on him what's up
for three my goodness 14 for the Angelo
Russell Russell coming right back down
on the floor a little push off yeah and
step back freeze over Evan Fournier to
dip the net believe I'm going to switch
out of it they do
Dinwiddie pretty moves no look shot
clock winding down
freeloading like just Westbank your
financial bridge and looking for us 'l
he doesn't have to leap as we've talked
about many games watching to shoot the
basketball Wow and the Atkinson calls
out of play Russell with five seconds
high screen Davis Russell fire
Donovan's reporter Court it was late
because it's working I think so
here's another one Farrell gets hung up
and Russell takes advantage of it
scrimmage at Oak Hill Academy and then
never quite got healthy at Duke Russell
again
on a3 love I off the rip Russell three
DeAngelo Russell is hitting nothing but
court watching staff at a heel short
Graham is there for the rebound
good job buddy hield Russell ice
D'Angelo Russell got a three she throws
the ball to the right take it Joe
no I'm not giving this one up either
Bank near the switch
Russell knocked out of his hands shot
clock at 12 got the matchup against the
big cauley-stein Russell of three holy
Stein's out there on the switch and I'm
sure what's going through his mind is I
really don't want to be out here right
now because he's even going to drive by
me or make a shot on me and are 9 of 18
from three-point territory 50% for the
Kings Russell reloading